we went to the second talk of the day
just a reminder that you're incorrect
you're encouraged to ask questions
throughout you can do so by typing in a
question to the Q&A box or you can raise
your hand and I will unmute you and you
can ask your question verbally so the
next talk will be given by Jo Emerson
from University of Waterloo and he'll be
telling us about cycle benchmarking Jo
great thank you thank you for the
opportunity to tell you about what we're
up to so this is actually joint work
with my group at the University of
Waterloo and people have to start up
quantum benchmark and so my co-authors
are listed there and so I'm gonna tell
you about the implemental
implementations of some theoretical
methods that were developed by myself
and Joel and others to do you understand
the errors impacting a quantum system
especially a quantum digital quantum
computer programmable on a computer and
and that has multiple out that
information can flow in various ways and
I'll describe that a bit as well and you
know I understand this is more of a
theory audience so and an audience is
not super familiar with benchmarking so
feel free to ask me to elaborate on any
of the background information ok great
so the first thing I want to emphasize
is that is the complexity of the error
problem so you know we've kind of
comforted ourselves with this idea that
we can talk about single numbers to
characterize you know a threshold or you
know error rates and you know I think
that you know that got us so far but we
really have to stop assuming that that's
a reasonable thing to do anymore you
know we have the exponential power of
quantum computing but the error
parameters in a quantum processor grow
even faster than exponential law I'm not
backing quite you know it's 2 to the 4 n
is what I mean rather than 2 to the N so
I'll explain in more detail
- to the foreign comes from but here if
we want to understand truly understand
the air parameters affecting an
implementation we have to worry about
this massive parameter space a point I'm
gonna emphasize throughout this talk
because it turns out even the experts on
this idea of characterization haven't
really fully appreciated
Robin Bloom Koon notwithstanding many
others haven't appreciated the
importance of the fact that the air is
depend on which gates are applied so
when I talk about to to the foreign air
parameters that's for each different
gate in principle that you have to apply
in your processor and each different
combination of gates and I'll show you
some very strong evidence that this is
not a second-order effect but a leading
order effect in characterizing the air
processes of course I'm making an a
Marco bian assumption I'm assuming the
errors are Markovian on the timescale of
the gates if that's not the case then
this is a completely positive map model
breaks down something which I for 10
years we're trying to convince Richard
Cleave up and he still doesn't believe
me but if you have non Markovian errors
this whole CP map formalism just isn't
doesn't even work so here i'm assuming
that we have CP maps and so the errors
are Markovian on the time scale of gates
and even with that assumption we still
have a very big challenge ahead of us so
here's the kind of a fun little slide
you know some of you know I'm an
entrepreneur as well as an academic now
so I've really been forced to simplify
these things these stories and so here's
kind of the simple picture I give to you
know venture capitalists and fortune 500
companies so you're trying to navigate
these waters to do a quantum computation
and you see these icebergs and you
obviously want to avoid them they're the
errors and the processes that are
associated with their transformation the
tip of the iceberg is what we can
measure by a randomized benchmarking or
gates that tomography these are the
errors associated with the gates
themselves and of course what's
happening underneath the surface is the
true danger and that is cross talk
errors correlated errors that are
severely limiting the performance of
processors it will severely impact the
capabilities
scaliger thumbs and fault-tolerance
going forward so first the visual is not
to scale I kind of realized that this
figure I make sure I found on the
Internet
is actually very badly out of scale it
looks like the bottom of the iceberg is
two or three times the size of the tip
that's not the case and similarly for a
quantum computer it's exponentially
larger and another piece the story I
mentioned at the top of the talk is that
look every iceberg is different you
can't measure one iceberg and say you
know all icebergs and the same mystery
you can't say I measured the air is
associated with some gates or with an
average over my gates because no
randomized benchmarking does and think
that you have enough information to
navigate these waters you have to
identify every single iceberg to be safe
and you have to identify the errors in
every distinct gate combination - and
then of course you have to understand
the errors and your measurements as well
but here we're just focusing on gate
operations for this talk and I'll show
you some data for that and the cycle
benchmarking is the tool that's going to
solve this problem maybe not completely
but to a very high degree of
satisfaction and so I'll tell you about
what that is today okay
so errors in a channel so which channel
is the point so if you're going to see a
lot of results out there about
characterizing errors in a channel but
then what's happening is they're
characterized in the air is in some kind
of average channel or abstract channel
so think about the difference between
quantum error correction and
fault-tolerant quantum error correction
so quantum error correction you have
some memory channel or some you know
communication channel you do an encoding
to survive the errors in that channel
and then you do a decode and of course
in a fault-tolerant setting you need to
worry about the errors that arise in the
operations themselves both the the
logical operations in the circuit these
target operations of the circuit but
also the operations you perform to do
the encoding and and the correction
steps the recovery steps and so the
problem is much more complex when you
think about the real world application
these ideas in a computation and the
same thing is happening with these
quantum processors today and in the
future which is that the errors depend
on the applied control on the microwaves
on the lasers on the system design
parameters of the trap which means they
depend on the choice of gates Robin has
made a point about this in several talks
he calls a gate error contextual and he
or gate contextual ax T and it's this
idea that the error is depending on the
context they depend on the choice of
gates on the sequence of gates that are
being applied on their own or in
parallel and so the point here which I'm
really belaboring now is that distinct
gate combinations produce distinct error
rates and types and so the cycle
benchmarking tool is really designed not
just you identify the errors in detail
but to identify the errors associated
with very specific gate combinations
that you care about for improving the
design of the device for applying error
correction and fault tolerance so just
to give you a quick now picture the
cycle benchmarking protocol is is the
following what you have in pink with the
vertical pink block is some gate some
set of gates you care about so this
could be maybe a parallel set of C phase
gates across the processor could be a
paralyze set of T gates it could be some
mixture of C phases and T gates give me
anything you want but the idea is that's
one kind of moment in the SIRT language
it's one clock cycle in that more
abstract language where you're applying
some set of gates across all the qubits
in your system which we know we have to
do to realize robust large-scale quorum
computing so that's what you care about
and then the blue gates are local
randomizing gates very much like what
andreas talked about in the previous
talk so these can be drawn from maybe
the poly group or the dihedral group on
single qubits
or the Clifford group so we think the
best way to do this in general is the
poly group so here you're doing random
Polly's and then the block that's grayed
out that's being applied M times
sequentially and the idea there
is to essentially get a decay curve and
by seeing the rate at which the fidelity
will decrease you're getting the error
per unit application of this block and
that allows you to isolate out spam
errors so spam errors are called our
so-called state preparation and
measurement errors so when you prepare
the state with these green blocks on the
left and you prepare the measurement
with the green blocks on the right those
processes have errors associated with
them as well as the raw readout errors
of the device itself and if you want to
isolate the errors in that in the in the
pink block or in the gray block you want
to make sure that you're modding out the
errors from from the spam and and so
that's that's the protocol so for
terminology we called gee a hard gate
cycle so the hard gate cycle like I said
earlier it could be the identity
operation it could be which is idling
the qubits it could be an entangling
gate or some parallel sediment tangling
gates could be anything you want and
then the natural thing to do is to
understand the error is not on the pink
block alone but the pink block combined
with local random gates so we call that
address cycle borrowing terminology from
physics we also call it a twirled hard
gate round and so what I'll tell you
later is about how that is the natural
thing to characterize the errors for for
now you just have to accept that on
faith and then basically what we're
doing is some clever sampling of input
States - the problem is the error model
will produce a multi exponential decay
and what we want to do is be able to
isolate single Exponential's to get a
good fit and so the green of the green
in addition to the em fold sequential
multiplication the green operations are
also killing off other decays so that
we're just singling out single
Exponential's associated with specific
input all the operators so the idea is
that the total error on this entire gray
block can be systematically explored by
looking at its impact on a basis a basis
being a set of poly input states and
what we want to do is we
sample from that set we want to isolate
the errors associated with the action of
this gate sequence on specific input
states or specific poly input operators
there who has a clean sorry the basic
question what is a poly greases State so
if you think about the Bloch sphere the
Bloch sphere is spanned by identity XY
and Z and if you take n fold tensor
products of those four poly operators
you get a set of Polly's and that is a
operator basis for the Louisville space
so the way that works is that you know a
unitary the basis for a unitary is the
computational basis so you have a matrix
for two qubits you have a four by four
matrix you have four basis states the
error models are C P max acting on that
space which are d squared by d squared
dimensional for d dimensional hilbert
space and so now the basis is also
bigger instead of the computational
basis you need a basis of four to the n
object and I'll actually come back to
that later in the talk but first let me
continue with kind of motivating why
this matters you know we have a diverse
audience so I think there's something
for everyone here and the idea is how is
this in this diagnostic information
we're gonna tease out who is it useful
to how is it useful and so the idea is
what people mainly do right now is they
implement their gates and they
characterize their gate performance via
single numbers which are determined by a
randomized benchmarking or they do
something more sophisticated like gate
set tomography and they get a set of
numbers associated with different
elementary gates and what I'm going to
show you later is that that's really
inadequate for understanding global
performance and so if we move down to
the blue bump box these are the global
errors estimated under cycle
benchmarking and the word global is not
the perfect word here what I'm talking
about is is aggregate errors so
essentially what you're going to see
later is that if I have a 10 cubed
system and I apply a gate on qubits 4 &
5 people traditionally have thought
about what is the
on the gate by looking at cubits four
and five well we're seeing my work with
almost all experimentalists now and what
we're seeing across all system is that
you can have very dominant errors that
aren't even on cubits four and five that
are induced by the gate on four and five
and the reason for that is that
experiments are hard right so in the
super done qubit system using microwaves
and microwaves are long and they
basically cover the whole chip and you
have any other qubits that are on
resonance with that frequency are going
to be excited and perturbed by the gate
operation and so you can see a big error
on qubit ten when you're just trying to
do a gate on qubits four and five so by
global what I mean is that we're looking
at the errors across the whole system
and what we're doing is we're
reconstructing the errors in what's
called a poly channel and I'll explain
why that's the right object later and
we're finding what I call off gate
errors occurring on other cubics under
each distinct clock cycle each distinct
combination in gates so now how is that
information useful so on the one hand
the people in the lab the
experimentalists in a lab need to
understand how to optimize their pulse
design optimize their system design
their system operating parameters and
and this information flows back to them
to do that engineering on the other hand
for misc applications we want to
understand what is the accuracy of the
algorithm what are different trade-offs
we can apply to find robust more robust
ways to implement the same global
unitary by a different break different
circuit decompositions and so I'll talk
a bit more about that at the end of the
talk if there's time and then an
exciting application is that if we as we
look towards fault-tolerant quantum
error correction we very much need to
understand whether or not not just is
the noise below the threshold which is a
very naive way of thinking about it but
what about all the other assumptions
that go into that fault tolerant
threshold are the air is independent or
the independent beyond some length scale
is the noise Markovian if we do have
high weight errors how high of weights
do we have to worry about are there
preferential errors along certain axis
systems in many experimental systems the
air is along the
that axis are completely different if
not negligible compared to errors for
rotations about the X and y axis because
there's different physics involved the
errors on the X and y-axis come from
physically hitting the systems with
pulses the air the Zetas axis rotations
are performed by just changing your
timing which is very accurate and so you
basically just redefined what your
rotating frame is to do is add rotation
which is error free basically so you
have a very strong asymmetry on the
different axis system for your errors
and that can be exploited to get big
gains in lowering the overhead for
achieving fault tolerance the other
thing you want to worry about is how to
optimize the decoder the decoder is will
depend on detailed information about the
noise to have the right prior to do the
best guess about how to do the best
recovery operation so the information
obtained from this flows in at multiple
levels whether you care about control
whether you care about misc algorithms
whether you care about fault tolerance
the information that our tool generates
is is relevant and all those
applications I'll pause for questions ok
now a little bit of math so a general
error' channel if we written down in
lots of ways a common way to write it
down is the so called Chi matrix so here
the Pauli's piece of alpha and piece of
beta are all the Polly's that span the
space so you have d squared of them in
the lower right hand corner p1 is the
tensor product of identities p2 as an X
on the enth qubit p3 is a Y on the enth
qubit and so on and so forth until you
have Zed's all the way across this is an
operator basis for the noise maps for
the CP maps and so we can write any CP
map in terms of this in terms of this
this is called the Chi matrix
representation it's similar to a cross
form but it has off off diagonal terms
alpha and beta can be unmatched and then
the Chi matrix is the set of
coefficients that contains the full
information about the CP map so that has
that kind matrix is dimension d squared
by d squared where D is the Hilbert
space
now there's a special subset of error
channels called poly error channels and
that's where we remove the off diagonals
so we just have matching indices and
then Denair then the error model is
described by a probability vector of
length d squared and we think about the
air channel in this context is having
just a distinct probability of any of
these d squared poly operations a
special case of this is the well-known
depolarizing error channel so a
depolarizing error channel in each qubit
would assume that the errors on XY and z
are the same and so you just have one
parameter to describe the errors on a d
dimensional system you can have a
depolarizing channel and it assumes that
the errors on all Polly's are the same
except for the probability of no error
which is distinct so these are very
physically unrealistic but simple error
models to work with mathematically and
so the key point here is a notion of
coherent errors so if my error model is
like a theoretical error model you would
say okay well I'm gonna I'm gonna dream
up this error model where I just have
some probability of an X error on qubit
one and different probability of an X
error and qubit - but these are all
classical statistical kind of models
these are classical models of noise I
have a classical probability of each of
these distinct Pauli operators happening
that is not what happens in the real
world so a very common leading error
mechanism for physical systems is say an
over rotation so I meant to do a 90
degree rotation or a PI on 2 rotation
about X and instead I did a PI on 2 plus
epsilon rotation that in fact tends to
be the leading err on almost all systems
when you have that kind of an error
model you do not have a poly error
channel you have off diagonal terms in
the Chi matrix and so so there are two
way to challenges' one is can we you
know obviously engineer systems so that
the noise is not of that form and so you
can work hard on that but one of the
things I'll tell you about in this talk
is a tool we developed called randomize
compiling
which is a way to enforce the air model
to have this poly air channel structure
which is a very convenient structure to
work with mathematically and what that
basically does is it applies random
gates you apply virtual random gates
kind of interleaved in your circuit and
then average over those virtual
randomizations
in a way that you kill off the off
diagonal terms and I'll touch on that a
bit in more depth later but that's just
to give you a sense that we can't even
though it's not physically realistic we
can use software tools to to reduce the
error model to this poly air channel so
now becomes very relevant because we
have this tool to make it relevant
so I already jumped ahead of myself so
the point is these poly channels are not
physically natural but as I mentioned on
the last slide we can enforce it through
randomized compiling so that we can get
this first of all randomize compiling
gets rid of these cross terms and the
second thing it does is it gets rid of a
lot of non Markovian errors so it forces
the air model to be more Markovian and
there was a nice experiment showing this
a couple years ago out of BBN and that
the point is now once we've once we've
done that or we assume that then we can
just simplify our problem understanding
this probability vector P alpha which is
a 2 2 to 2 n dimensional probability
vector of which depolarizing error is a
very special case okay now a little more
math so in general an CP map is can be
written in this Kraus form or this with
the probability vector but that's not
actually the most natively that's not
the most natural way to describe air
across disease a quantum a CP map is a
linear map which basically means that a
great way to think about it is just as a
matrix act acting on a vector and so the
way to do that is you have this map
lambda which is just a linear map taking
input States to output States and now
what we can do is we can expand the
input state across a basis of operators
which is just going to be our poly
operators and the coefficients B alpha
and code which state you have and then
they're calculated by the Hilbert
Schmidt inner product
and then similarly for the output state
and then what we can do is we can
represent the map itself by the helpers
mini inner product under the following
trace which now means our CP map is
represented by a matrix which acts on
the vector i's form of the density
operator as too many of you are familiar
with this but if you're not this is such
a great way to think about air models
you should know it and then and then
what you acquire is that all these
natural properties so now this map does
matrix lambda is we call the dynamical
error matrix because our dynamical
matrix because if you have an error
process associated with some time tau
and then you have another error process
associated with a second time oh let's
call it tau 1 and tau 2 then you can
just multiply the matrices together and
understand the process from across both
times and so the entire problem of error
analysis is just the linear algebra of
analyzing these matrices
it's very mathematically natural it's
composable both under in time and in
space so you can tensor product these
matrices together to see the error
process across two systems that are
independent and if these systems are not
independent correlations will show up in
the error process matrix for the joint
system and if you choose the basis B
alpha to be the poly operators then this
Newville matrix is called the poly
transfer matrix so that's the tool I
will use it's a very key tool for
analyzing this now because we have a
linear matrix if that linear matrix is
normal we can diagonalize it and the
singular values then encode key
information about the error process now
if we know we have a if we know for
other reasons that this error process is
a Pauline channel then a poly channel
expressed in the poly operator basis as
a poly transfer matrix will be a
diagonal matrix and the eigenvalues
contain the complete information and
they relate directly to the poly Krauss
picture so here now if we have a poly
channel we have d squared I ghen values
and the poly operators are the
eigenvectors of that channel associated
with their own eigenvalues and
correlations in the noise will be
encoded in the relationships between
these eigenvalues and this was shown or
I mean I think it's been known for a
long time but we explicitly explored
this back in 2007 where we showed that
by measuring these quantities or
sampling them and estimating them you
could learn about correlations in the
air model of an error channel and then
what happened in 2019 in our work with
Innsbruck we demonstrated this cycle
benchmarking tool and what that does is
it is it allows you to associate these
this information not with some abstract
error channel but the error is
associated with very specific
combinations of gates so now we can pull
out information about the correlations
in the errors associated with each
distinct gate sequence and then if you
like thinking about it in terms of this
Crouse picture there's a very simple
relationship that relates these
eigenvalues to the probabilities in the
cross fixture so we have this two very
nice complimentary pictures and a simple
transformation between them and then now
what I'm going to show you is a preview
of what you're gonna get so the next two
figures are preview figures so if you
don't understand everything about them
that's okay
I just wanted to give you a sense of
where the talk is going so here's the
experimental data from that 2019 paper
with Innsbruck what we did is we said
let's just take a trap with 10 with up
to 10 ions in it and here we're looking
at a set up subset of 4 and we did a
complete reconstruction of the errors on
the 4 cubed system and then again the
question has errors on what so here the
errors are not on some average Channel
that they're the errors on the identity
Channel where the only operations are
averaging over the local poly operators
and so then the local poly operators
enforce the noise to be a poly channel
so we know with high confidence that the
channel is given by this poly Crouse
picture and that the only relevant
information is these probabilities and
these probabilities correspond to
specific input states that span the
space of input states these these poly
Basie's these poly operators and then
what you find is in blue you find the
one body errors so the the biggest error
they see is this three does point three
percent probability of an of an X air on
qubit one and no errors on qubits two
three and four the second biggest error
is an X by bit flip air on qubit four
and no errors on the other qubits and so
on well where this gets interesting
I mean of course that's great
information for improving your pulse
design where this gets interesting is
look at the orange so the orange are the
weight two errors these are errors with
Hamming weight too and not only is it
telling you the total probability of
weight two errors which is this point
zero zero three two here but it's
telling you the specific probabilities
associated with specific correlations
and noise and notice that these are
coming in at the point one percent level
just below point one percent and so you
have a correlation from qubit one and
three along the x-axis and xx coupling
you have a Zed Zed coupling between
qubits one and three then you have an XY
coupling between qubits one and two and
so on so the most interesting thing
about this for theorists I mean for
experimentalist this information is a
goldmine for theorists think about the
assumption we've all been hoping for
which is the errors are independent
across qubits so that our high threshold
fault-tolerant proofs apply if the
errors are independent across qubits
then the the errors of way too should be
quadratically suppressed relative to the
errors of weight one so if you have a
probability if you have a ten to the
minus two error rate for single qubit
errors your weight two errors should be
ten to the minus four right just as like
if you're flipping coins if you have a
you have a highly biased coin or you
know you're rolling a d 100 what's the
chance of getting a 1 it's 1 out of 100
if you roll twice what are the chances
of getting two ones very small
right 10 to the minus 4 these errors are
coming in three times smaller than the
single qubit errors so what that means
is that there's very very strong two
body errors when they're only doing one
body gates so they remember what we're
characterizing here are the errors on
one body gates just doing single qubit
Ollie's so this is bad news in the sense
that we're very far in this device from
having uncorrelated errors now there's
two solutions for that one solution is
to you know put the team back in the lab
and you know use this information to
improve the design of the control and
the other solution is to look at error
models of air correction procedures that
can handle wait two errors and by
looking at the thigh the diagnostic
information you can say well if my if I
have I can choose a code with the right
distance to handle the bulk of the
errors that I'm worried about and so
here we're at the first step of a very
long iterative process but what we now
have and what I'm kind of showcasing
here is that we now have the right tool
to take on this challenge from both the
top and the bottom so get the teams in
the lab figuring out how to improve the
design get the therasphere on a design
the right codes to tackle the air models
with these different gate combinations
what about super done qubit systems so
we ran experiments on IBM q so this is
the yorktown device which is one of
their first generation v cubed chips
they put online this data is astonishing
so the way IBM describes its devices is
they report randomized benchmarking
numbers for their one and two qubit
gates right so what we do is we run a
see not gate on cubed 0 1 as our hard
gate round so that pink block labeled by
G earlier in the talk and then we idle
qubits 2 3 & 4 and then we apply the
cycle benchmarking procedure which
involves applying local random Polly's
and then and then amplifying the errors
and then measuring now what you see on
this figure is the
x axis labels looking at different pairs
so the data set for this is huge so this
is a projection of the data to for
visualization and so we're looking at is
the pair 0 1 in the first column the
pair of 0 2 in the second column and so
on and then what the y-axis is is each
of the Polly operators that span that 2
cubed space so in other words not just
how much error occurred but where did it
occur in the Hilbert space and this
vertical column for qubits for the 0 1
pair which is the only pair of good not
now just as a rule of thumb for
theorists the C not gate error rates
tend to be 10 times bigger than the
single qubit gates so the errors are the
dominant errors here from the C not gate
what you see is that the oh sorry lastly
this is a heat map so dark colors mean
low errors bright colors mean high error
rates what you see is the first column
is looking at the errors on qubit 0 1
and what you see is a very dark purple
which is loosely speaking the randomized
benchmarking number that IBM reports for
there see not gate is summing over the
vertical column for the first column and
what that shows it is good performance
now for them good is like 10 to the
minus 2 error rates what they don't show
from that data is then when you look at
what's happening elsewhere on the chip
and the rest of the chip has these very
bright colors everywhere so what we're
seeing is that error rates of 10 to
minus 2 on this from the C not gate but
the crosstalk errors induced by the C
naught or creating weight one and some
weight to errors at totally different
locations on the chip look at column
three four cubits three and four on the
other side of the chip and you see a
bright green on Z I so what you have is
a very big phase shift error on qubit 3
that's being induced by the C naught
gate on qubit 0 and 1 and before we did
this experiment we thought ok maybe the
crosstalk errors will be 1 percent or 10
percent of the error budget
they're not only there they're 10 times
bigger than the errors on the sea not so
the sea nautious errors of 10 to minus 2
the air is on the rest of the ship are
at the 10 to the minus 1 scale so what
can you give any intuition about why
it's so piqued on these is there a
pattern here that we should know that
you can read off this chart yeah so yeah
so for example look at cubed 0 2 you see
the bright yellow and then the cubed
pair is 1 & 2 you see a bright yellow on
the second qubit so what that means is
cubit too so notice that this is
overkill because now when you're looking
at single body errors that essentially 0
here and the 1 here is irrelevant the
point is what this saying is there's a
very large phase flip error on cubit 2
and shows up as the shadows of that
error show up in different ways on this
figure okay so basically what they're
showing there's a very strong phase
shift error on qubit to there's a very
strong phase shift error on qubit 3 and
then and that shows up in different ways
here and then what you see in kind of in
a lighter blue you see errors you see
Zed Zed X ed and Y Zed errors on the
zero for pair so these are two body
errors so those are not as easily fixed
by a simple phase Corrections okay
thanks so in other words remember the
way we do the cross resonance gate is
you basically apply control and that
induces a coupling so if you're just
trying to do a scene out on zero one
you're actually accidentally going to
induce like partial C nots elsewhere on
the chip and also single qubit phase
shifts and so this information is
basically telling you what went wrong
how did it go wrong were they to Cuban
errors 1 cubed errors and and this
pattern looks completely different for
every gate combination ok thanks
ok and yeah so that's the preview and
I'll come back to this again later with
more when you guys have more of a
background from the rest of the talk
alright so now I kind of go back to
basics what are ways to estimate errors
well these very simple errors
characterizations are based on
Fidelity's so the average gate fidelity
is you look at the
process epsilon or e how does it what's
its average action across states you the
so called RB number or the infidelity
for randomized benchmarking is just one
minus that number often use with the
letter e R is often used for that a
common a common measure of error figure
of Merit for error in fault tolerance is
the diamond metric the diamond alarm and
you know that's a proper distance metric
that's composable and so on and that's
by taking the diamond norm between the
error process and identity and just to
make sure everyone's on the same page
here I'm always imagining that you're
modding out the intended gate and just
looking at the error on that gate
another interesting figure of Merit is
the total variational distance or l1
norm on the probability distribution
under some circuit so I have an ideal
circuit I have the actual implementation
they both induce probability
distributions I mean a computational
basis and then I can measure the impact
of the errors by summing over the
absolute value of these differences so
these are three common ways to measure
errors the data I was showing you on the
previous slide is kind of the full
information and then these are these
figure of Merit metrics which you could
compute from that full information an
important story is that Norman Bates
metrics all behaved kind of similarly
and they're very sensitive to coherent
errors so this inequality here is is a
very important piece of information
about understanding the impact of errors
so on the left-hand side of this
inequality is the infidelity which is
measured by randomized benchmarking and
this fact is you know there's a
dimensional factor of D plus 1 over D
which is basically 1 in the middle we
have the diamond norm which upper bounds
the infidelity and then on the right
hand side we have the square root of the
infidelity times a huge dimensional
factor the hilbert space dimension which
upper bounds the diamond norm so so now
the problem is the diamond norms not
easy to measure
but the infidelity is very easy to
measure and so the point is how does how
does this knowledge relate to itself how
do these things relate to each other
rather and so what you have is because
of this inequality on the right-hand
side if I measure a randomized
benchmarking number and I get 10 to the
minus 4 error rates what does that tell
me about the diamond law well the best I
can do without other information is take
the square root and multiply by the
hilbert space dimension and what that
means is that if i want to talk about
comparing my RB number to threshold
based on the diamond norm the square
root is going to crush me so i measure i
do all this hard work and get 10 to
minus 4 error rates really that means i
could only pass a threshold of 10 to
minus 2 and again this is doing the
naive thing we were saying we're
assuming the noise is independent or
assuming it's Markovian it's none of
those things but if all of those happy
things were true
my nose was depolarizing and that I'm
just checking now you know is it what is
the threshold I can pass well if I do
randomized benchmarking sorry I misspoke
if it's depolarizing then actually
you're in good shape but if you don't
know that it's depolarizing you just
know that it's independent then you get
the square root factor so that's a major
challenge how can we overcome that and
the trick is to make sure that I'm
missing a slide here so let me just say
something verbally what we know about
this inequality is the following the
upper bound the this upper bound is
saturated by coherent errors so if the
error is in one of these you know
physically realistic over-rotation
errors then I have these off diagonal
terms and if these off diagonal terms
that give this square root if I know the
noise is a stochastic noise or so it's a
poly channel then the lower bound is
saturated so if I have a promise that
the errors are a poly channel we're in
fact more generally any stochastic
channel so there's no off diagonal terms
then in fact this inequality is
saturated and the RB number is a very
good proxy up to some small dimensional
factor
the diamond norm so it kills the
square-root basically so that's that's
that's the strength of randomized
compiling is that it gets rid of this
square root problem and now when the
numbers we measure via cycle
benchmarking and randomized benchmarking
now actually can be used to compare
directly to the threshold without the
square root
and so I think these points are
basically the points of our made and the
important story here is that the the
total variational distance acts like the
diamond norm so it's bounded it's
bounded by the diamond norm bounded by
the diamond norm so we similarly can can
predict the algorithmic accuracy for a
circuit from these infidelity numbers if
we're promised that the noise is
stochastic so that's why we think the
right way forward is to always use
randomized compiling then you're
guaranteed that you have a very close
tight connection between all of the
quantities you care about how do you
determine if your errors are still
coherent well with randomized compiling
you can get rid of it now you don't
fully get rid of it what you do is you
you get rid of the square root
so if coherent error that comes in as a
square root becomes a stochastic error
and only comes in as the raw RB number
so it doesn't make the queered error
disappear it turns it into a more benign
stochastic error now if you're for the
engineering teams in the lab you know
that there's now two ways you can get
rid of your cool hearing errors one is
you can just let them be
use randomize compiling and suppress
them quadratically the other thing you
can do is of course improve your tune-up
and control and so if your job is to
improve your pulse design then you want
to directly measure the amount of
unitarity and one way to do this is via
this unitarity protocol which measures
this quantity you which is essentially
the average shrinking of the vector and
the generalized Bloch sphere so
basically what you you you measures is
if I imagine my vector in the Bloch
sphere the noise will rotate it and come
and shrink it and what unitarity does is
it measures the amount of shrinking
without caring about how much it got
rotated so if you measure the total
error and you measure the compression
error the depolarizing error then by
having those two pieces of information
you know how much it actually got
rotated and so this is a complementary
tool set by this unitarity protocol to
do this and so that's something that's
mostly of interest to experimentalists
you want to
kind of optimally tuned up there
controls let me just skip over that for
this audience now let me show what we
learned about on the IBM system this is
now their 14 qubit device Mel born and
to emphasize this story of crosstalk so
this is pretty old data now we looked at
qubits 0 through 13 on the x axis and on
the y axis is the error rate this
infidelity number and we did in blue
with blue circles is we just pulse on
one qubit at a time and run a randomized
benchmarking experiment so randomized
benchmarking separators just apply a
random sequence of gates see how fast
you lose fidelity and from the slope you
infer the error rate per operation and
and then what we did and that's the blue
that's the blue dots the blue circles
and you see the error rates we intend to
mine you know around 3 times 10 to the
minus 3 pretty consistently across the
system then what we did is instead of
idling the other 13 qubits we did
randomized benchmarking in parallel so
we're pulsing now on all the qubits
simultaneously but not entangling them
intentionally in any way and then what
you see as an orange is the local RB
number when instead of idling the other
qubits are actually pulsing on the other
qubits and so qubit zero when you go
from idling qubits 1 through 13 to
pulsing on them at the same time you see
a jump of a big factor of 3 in the error
rate for qubit one you see a jump of
almost an order of magnitude in the
local error rate why is this happening
because the pulses you're applying to
qubits 0 & 2 through 13 are leaking onto
qubit 1 and inducing errors on it so in
other words like we saw earlier and now
this is single qubit gates not the C not
gate so even the single qubit gates are
causing crosstalk errors that are
inducing errors on qubits you're not
intending to be acting on and then a
crosstalk error you often has a very
strong coherent error signature because
it's actually
the microwave balls is producing a
rotation so it's not a depolarization or
D phasing but just a flat-out rotation
an incorrect rotation of the qubit so we
use this unitarity protocol which is the
squares to determine what fraction of
the noise is d is depolarizing versus
coherent and what you see is in the in
the isolated RB case where everything
else is idle you see that the squares
and the circles align very well the blue
square and the blue circle are very well
aligned what that means is that iBM is
very effectively calibrated their
systems when they're not looking at
other qubits being acted on but now when
you're acting on the other qubits you
see a big gap opening up between the
squares and the circles and that's
because of the crosstalk so now we're
seeing as a very large coherent so a
very big jump in the error and a big
portion of that jump is some simple
static or systematic over rotation of
the cubed for those gates so this is
really a slide that's of more interest
to experimentalist and the theorists so
unless there's any questions I'll skip
ahead now I'll tell you more about
randomized compiling so once the
experimentalists have done all the work
they can do to remove as many coherent
errors as possible through pulse design
you will still have coherent errors and
so now what we want to do is we want to
remove them effectively through a
software layer and so randomized
compiling takes um some sample circuit
at the top here where different colors
represent different single qubit gates
whether it's an X rotation a bit flip or
a PI onto gate or a t gate or a phase
gate and then we divide the circuit into
rounds of single qubit gates and two
qubit gates this is a simple example
there's other ways to do it and then
what we do is then we insert virtually
in our pre-processing we insert random
Polly gates or there's other general
groups you can apply and then we
calculate the correction gate so if
there's no two qubit gate then the
correction gave is the inverse of the
gate you apply and this is virtual if
there is a two qubit gate
the yellow in the second and the second
figure the yellow becomes red so now we
compute what is the correct correction
gate after you commute through the
yellow gate through the C naught well
then you what's the correction gate I
need to do to get rid of it so with
these correction gates I've now undone
the randomness I induced but now we
don't apply any of these this is all
pre-processing and now you look at the
second round of single qubit gates you
apply a new set of totally iid random
single qubit gates from your twirling
set normally the Polly's but there's
other groups and then you compute all
that in advance notice that to do this
to cook virtually randomized correct and
then virtually randomized and correct
all of your pre computations are in a
4x4 Hill four by four dimensional
hilbert space so the complexity of this
problem scales linearly with the gate
complexity okay so it's it's completely
trivial to do and then what you do set
out instead of applying these virtual
weights let me just compile in all of
these virtual gates and so the
interesting case is in this third column
I take the correction gate I take the
intended target gate I take the new
random virtual gate I multiply them all
together and find the new single qubit
rotation that does all of that and now
instead of applying my original circuit
I apply this randomized circuit and if
you're lucky this adds no gate depth no
circuit depth now you may say oh well a
lot of these like vqe algorithms and so
on you have these C naught ladders so
there's no single qubit layers and she
says that means I'm gonna double my gate
dad so yeah maybe it doubles your gate
depth but in reality if you're running
this on on a system what is the native
gate in the system the native gate on
the IBM system is not a C naught gate
it's a cross resonance gate how do they
deliver a C naught gate to the user they
sandwich their cross resonance gate
between sets of single qubit gates to
rotate into the equivalent C naught so
really there's a hidden layer of single
qubit gates in a lot of these systems
and so even when you think you don't
you're not adding you would have to add
depth you actually don't have to add
depth by this trick and so I think it's
an interesting open scientific question
how often you would add some you know
doubling or fractional depth and I'd
like to know more about that but in many
settings you actually add no depth at
all and then of course the upside is you
create a stochastic channel so you get
rid of the square root problem which is
a huge benefit and so here we look at
some numerix that notice the total
variational distance is a great way to
think about it which is it's basically
the probability of getting the wrong bit
string so if I am producing some bit
string ideally which is some probability
then TVD measures what's the probability
I didn't get the right bit string and so
what this is showing basically is that
if your errors are purely coherent like
they might be from crosstalk or
calibration errors then you get a huge
gain with randomized compiling if your
errors are natively stochastic then you
get no gain from randomize compiling and
so if there's just a scaling there
that's I'll skip really quickly how many
randomizations do you need so the trick
is you create these virtual circuits you
compile them to get a new random circuit
how many different random circuits do
you have to run well the answer is at
most 20 so in terms of the overhead of
number of runs it's a factor of 20 now
notice you're going to be running
multiple runs anyways to accumulate
statistics so really this is a cost that
experimentalists care about because it's
how often do they have to reload the ref
BGA
but from a theorist point of view this
is a trivial cost now here's some data
so this is data showing how how well
randomized compiling works on IBM q so
here I'm looking at the TV D on the
y-axis I'm looking at various circuit
lengths on the x-axis orange circles are
the error the probability of an
incorrect solution as I increase the
circuit depth looking at deterministic
circuit it's on the Left column random
circuits on the right column so yes even
if your circuit is random applying
randomized compiling helps the errors
are kind of crazy and very scattered in
the random circuit case
and you see kind of coherent
oscillations in the lower left corner
from the fact that the interplay of the
coherent errors can be destructive or
constructive and so coherent errors are
funny that way but what what randomized
compiling does is it reduces the air
across the board and it creates stable
performance in another wise very
unstable environment alright just a
heads up we want to leave a few minutes
for questions to wrap up by - just great
so let me just skip this piece you saw
this data already here's where I walk
through the earlier data more carefully
and I just I pretty much explain this
all of you but now you can appreciate so
recycle benchmarking you have this kind
of Christmas tree of errors occurring on
qubits that aren't in the action of the
gate
and so basically RB measures this which
is very misleading the true errors are
the true errors are ten times bigger and
they're not seen by RB at least
certainly not isolated RB I talked more
about okay let's skip that move so in
terms of tools for assessing these error
Diagnostics the point now being that
cycle benchmarking recovers the errors
in this stochastic picture I've tried to
convince you with randomized compiling
those are the errors relevant to the
invivo performance there is this tool
called symmetrized error
characterization which we proposed back
in 2007 which really imagines some
abstract error channel it could look at
some correlations it was efficient and
scalable Steve will tell you later about
an implementation he did with Robin
Harper and Joel Waldman which they
called efficient learning that looks at
errors averaged over all the gates so
it's not giving you the errors
associated with particular gate
combinations it sees some but not all
correlations and I'm really going out of
my way to make this point because for
reasons I don't understand and they're
paper on the archive they imply they get
all error correlations which is not the
case and it's questionable whether it's
really an efficient implementation but
the point is the data I just showed you
today and the tool I described today
identifies
all relevant correlations it identifies
them for any gate gate combination of
interest and it's efficient and scalable
so we think it's the right tool going
forward
I think in the interest of time I'll
skip this this is on the five qubit chip
we look at the at the aggregate error
for so these five cubed chips are in
this t design and here we do a C naught
gate on this pair in the second column
we do have C not get another pair over
on the right-hand columns we do parallel
C not gates two different combinations
of parallel C not gates
this is actually an exhaustive set of
all two qubit gates and gate
combinations you can apply on there five
qubit chips burlington essex london we
did it twice on warrants and Vigo and
what you see is just very different
error profiles in the aggregate error
for each of these gate combinations what
this allows us to do is predict now
imagine you're gonna run a circuit an
application like Bernstein Vaz irani or
hidden shift you can break that down
into a set of distinct cycles and then
you can use cycle benchmarking to
understand the error rate of each of
those cycles the global error rate and
then to understand how that algorithm
perform now we can have a lookup table
and we say here are the errors
associated with each of these gate
combinations now we can just add them up
stochastically and get the total error
budget under that application and so
here what we're doing is projecting how
well each of the devices can perform an
application based on doing the cycle
benchmarking to air characterize the
errors on each of the allowed to qubit
gate combinations and so you see the
various devices out of all of these
which one is it I think Vigo is by far
the best so it has a so what we call it
the Q cap bound the capacity of the
hardware to run the algorithm and I
think I'm running out of time so I'll
take some questions thanks for your
attention
all right questions you can raise your
hand alright um we had one in the Q&A
box so can you comment on how non
Markovian OT changes the performance are
there any indicators and cycle
benchmarking that hint to the existence
of non Markovian errors even though we
can't completely characterize them yeah
it's true so look so it can detect non
Markovian errors as follows when you do
a cycle benchmarking experiment you
would typically you know you repeat that
thing M times if you remember from my
older slide and I don't show any raw
data for this but you do this M fold
combination of the repetitions of the
gate and what that will do with the air
is our Markovian that will produce an
exponential decay decay so if your fit
does not fit an exponential if your data
does not fit an exponential you know for
randomized benchmarking and we haven't
proven rigorously for cycle benchmarking
but I see no reason why we couldn't push
it through just a bookkeeping problem if
you see a deviation from an exponential
that tells you that you have non
Markovian errors now that said it's a
one-sided test so there will be some non
Markovian errors that can be hidden so
you'll get a good fit to an exponential
or your various Poly's you sample and
you could still have non Markovian
errors that you're not witnessing
through the failure of the fit so if the
fit works you may have residual non
Markovian errors otherwise but I think
the natural thing to do is to do
something similar to what BBN did which
is to you know combine this with GST or
something and actually characterize how
how you know they have a good and non
Markovian flag test in GST and so you
could look at that that way
so yeah thanks for the talk it's so I
kind of I'm still trying to wrap my head
around when you say that when you run
this poly randomization it kind of
suppresses the coherent errors so is it
you know it's somehow kind of virtual
and the way this error suppressed like
it's not you know physically it's not
really being suppressed right so so what
does it mean how should I understand
what's happened yeah it's actually yeah
it's a bit mind-bending um let me try to
give you an analogy with classical
physics you know it's um it's
astonishing how much of all this can be
understood by thinking effectors in
three-dimensional space so if you're
trying to rotate a vector by 90 degrees
and you have a coherent error so you
instead you rotate it by 91 degrees here
I'm just talking about you know
Cartesian school now what randomized
compiling does is it basically virtually
flips the process so you wanted to
rotate about the y axis you want to
rotate X to Zed you rotate by 91 degrees
instead of 90 now the point is instead
of doing that you can what's the right
way to think about this I'm probably
gonna screw this up but you might see
the right way to explain it the idea is
by doing say a flip of the problem
around some axis you're going to be able
to effectively when you average over
runs you'll have a cluster of vectors
around the x axis differing by one
degree around the z axis different but
along different did the errors will be
different you'll have a cone of errors
around the intended vector through
inserting random gates so instead of
doing exactly a 90 degree rotation about
Y instead you apply a bit flip before
and after and then I'm screwing up the
example but the upshot of this is that
you you see that you will have a cone of
vectors around the target vector when
you average over runs and then the
average over that cone is what you
measure and the average of the cone will
be a shortened vector so the effective
noise will be a ad polarized vector an
attenuated vector
it is actually exactly on axis you know
what statistically you think you know I
see it now yeah
yeah I think I see so it's it's in each
run it's not that the the error has been
suppressed but you're kind of making the
error go in different directions you're
so you're sort of forcing there to go in
different directions and they average
out to some noncoherent another way to
think about it is if you look at a
rotation matrix in three dimensions you
have coasts theta sine theta minus sine
theta cos theta as your 2x2 matrix in
your three-dimensional space and then
and then basically with randomization
you're essentially take turning theta 2
minus theta half the time and so then
when you average the channel by just
straight statistical averaging half of
them will be sine theta the other half
will be minus sine theta so the
diagonals stay the same so think of
theta as the air is that one degree
error so half the time you have signed
at half time you have minus sine theta
that attenuates the off diagonals but
leaves the diagonals the same so that's
the sense in which you you remove a
coherent error by just seeing its
diagonal component which is the coup
Stata term I think cool that was very
helpful
Joe this is Robin quick question thank
you for a nice talk I had a question
about the slide where you showed a sort
of a bar chart of different weight
errors for the ion trap experiment yeah
and I yeah so you say here that the hard
round is the identity operation and
usually in an ion trap identities are
really good and I'm surprised to see any
wait for errors I mean if this was a
moment orin-san round or something I
could see weird things happening but
these are usually amazingly good gates
yeah so that's a great question and so
we've talked with them about that so
there's two solutions one is a failure
to suppress the vibrational modes
which are always present but you're
trying to suppress them the second I
think the dominant effect here is that
the way that the Innsbruck group does
its single qubit gaze is they apply a
global X and then they use individual
Zed gates and then they use Zed gates to
either mod out or or manipulate the
local gate to not be an X so in other
words the way they do independent single
qubit gates is they do a global X gate
followed by independent Zed gates on
each qubit followed by another global X
gate followed by another set of
independent Zed gates and in that way
you can get what's mathematically
independent su2 rotations on each qubit
using you know the usual Euler formula
what's it called yeah but they're
actually using global control to do
independent gates so I think I think
that's probably the dominant error does
that make sense
so maybe I think it sounds like what
you're saying is maybe the errors you're
seeing here are actually produced by
those single qubit poly twirling gates
not by the hard round itself oh sorry
yeah let me let me just be clear about
the terminology so what the errors
you're seeing are the errors on
addressed heart rate and yeah you're
exactly right so here if the hard round
is identity the dressed hard round
includes these random Polly's but now to
do the random Polly's so you're actually
seeing the errors just on the random
Polly's so yeah probably didn't explain
that super clearly so the errors you saw
there were just on iid random Polly
gates on each qubit the reason why we
see these high weight errors in their
system is partially because of
vibrational modes that haven't been
suppressed partially because of the fact
that they do IID in the individual qubit
rotations via a global X gate and
therefore you know they will have kind
of global fluctuations that will affect
all the qubits simultaneously even
though they're only trying to do
independent gates was that yeah
all right well thank you Joe all right
thank you for organizing whistles we
appreciate it